with a verve and swagger nicholas
sarkozy dominated french politics
for much of the early 2000s can now be
remembered for something else
first ex-president to get a custodial
sentence for corruption charges
the news has come as quite a shock to
the french everybody expected
nicolas sarkozy to get away with either
a fully suspended sentence or be
acquitted on some technicality
and so this really came as a shock
because he's the
first former president to be sentenced
to prison
[Applause]
sarkozy was found guilty of trying to
bribe a judge offering him a top job
in return for information about an
investigation into him
disgrace for a man who was known for his
brash and showy style of leadership as
president
and for his marriage to supermodel and
singer carla bruni who sent him a
message of sympathy via instagram
what a senseless witch hunt my love she
wrote in french
the fight will continue the truth will
see the light hashtag injustice
decision we will appeal against this
decision the president
of course disputes the sentence we're
both unable to understand
and indignant about the sentence it
didn't because
if you've attended these three weeks of
hearings like me
the feeling we have today listening to
the case delivered by the court
is that this decision is totally out of
step with the hearing
from 2007 to 2012 sarkozy strutted the
world stage
alongside fellow leaders as french
president
he now joins the select group of
ex-leaders tainted by corruption
from italy silvio berlusconi to jacques
cherak who received two years suspended
sentence
for misdeeds committed as mayor of paris
sarkozy claimed he was a victim of
unfair persecution by investigators
he protested his innocence and intends
to appeal
if he fails the judge says he can avoid
jail by wearing an electronic bracelet
at home
taking him from ex-president to tagged
felon
he had said he wouldn't run for
president again but many didn't believe
him
his political career seems over now
dominic waghorn sky news